we're constantly bombarded with trailers
posters and concept art for franchise
films but there are a few big sequels
coming out that have stayed under the
radar from indie comedies to biblical
epics let's take a look at some of the
sequels you didn't know were being made
the Pirates of the Caribbean films have
continued to rake in money at the box
office but after five movies their
appeal among audiences and critics has
been waning the latest installment 2017
Stedman tale no tales sits at an abysmal
30 percent of rotten tomatoes it raises
the question of whether more pirate
sequels are warranted but it looks like
Disney has decided to test the waters by
dusting off the franchise for at least
one more outing Ted Elliot's co-writer
of the first four pirates movies has
been tapped to come up with a new
adventure alongside Chernobyl scribe
Craig Mazin although this new pirates
film has been referred to as a reboot
the writers in studio reportedly haven't
yet settled on a direction for the sixth
film among the questions still up in the
air
whether or not it will include Johnny
Depp's swaggering hard-drinking
character Captain Jack Sparrow
despite Captain Jack's popularity Johnny
Depp's Hollywood appeal has been on the
decline in recent years bringing
uncertainty as to whether the studio
will want to risk hanging a fresh new
pirates tail on his shoulders or whether
the lot to move on to a new star we'll
have to wait to see whether the sixth
Pirates of the Caribbean is a sequel
reboot or something in between
until then drink up me hearties yo ho
although producer Phil Lord has said
that the team behind the Jump Street
movies is putting a pin in 23 Jump
Street which would mark the third outing
for 21 and 22 Jump Street stars Channing
Tatum and Jonah Hill the studio is
moving forward with the spin-off of the
comedy franchise this time focusing on a
female duo the first new Jump Street
films followed a pair of male cops who
went undercover at educational
institutions in order to ferret out
elusive drug suppliers presumably the
plot of 24 Jump Street would be much in
the same vein and would exist in the
same universe as the existing Jump
Street films functioning as a
continuation of the story started by
officers Morten Schmidt and Greg Jenko
in the first movie this time the stars
at the center of the Jump Street tale
will reportedly be Tiffany Haddish and
zendaya whom we assume will both be
playing undercover narcotics officers
similar to Tatum and Hills carrot
in the first two movies after directing
the first two Jump Street films Chris
Miller and Phil Lord will be stepping
aside for this third outing and Rodney
Rothman is coming aboard to helm the
spin-off collaborating on the script
with Bob's Burgers writers Lizzy and
Wendy Milano Rothman previously helped
write the screenplay for 22 Jump Street
and co-directed Lord and Miller's
acclaimed animated film spider-man into
the spider-verse no word yet on what the
plot will entail or whether Schmitter
Jenko will make an appearance start your
engines because it sounds like a sequel
to 2017 s motor tastic heist hit baby
driver may eventually be zooming its way
into production according to Ansel
Elgort the star of the first film not
only is writer director Edgar Wright
eager to make a sequel but he has in
fact already penned the script and
Elgort has read it yes I think it's
gonna happen I think Toby baby driver to
it has a different title actually as for
what the plot of a baby driver sequel
would look like right told Empire in
2017 with most sequels you have to
contrive something so they go back to
square one unless there's somewhere
deeper for them to go I think with baby
driver there's more that you can do in
that realm and I sort of have an idea
that if you did another one you would
subvert his involvement in the crime in
a different way so he's not kind of the
apprentice anymore
due to Elgort s'en rights existing
commitments it could still be a while
before baby driver 2 moves into
production and it sounds like once
things do move ahead with the high speed
sequel it'll be worth checking out
coming off the runaway success of 2018 s
crazy rich Asians it would have been
surprising if the opulent film didn't
earn a sequel in fact it's getting 2
based on Kevin's books of the same names
China rich girlfriend and rich people
problems are both movie to hand at
Warner Brothers although it may be a
while before we get to see them due to
the busy schedules of the franchise's a
list cast and director Jon M Chu who is
currently working on adapting lin-manuel
Miranda's musical in the heights for the
big screen
there may be a wait before everyone can
get together again for the next two
installments in the crazy rich Asian
saga
however producer Nina Jacobson says that
the plan is to shoot both sequels
back-to-back so that fans aren't waiting
years between the second and third films
Jacobson promises will make it up to
them on the back end by shooting two
films together as for when this
back-to-back shooting might happen it
could still be a ways off
according to actress Gemma Chan who
portrayed Polish socialite Astrid Liang
on China rich girlfriend and rich people
problems will begin sometime in quote
2020 at the earliest making the soonest
we can expect China rich girlfriend late
2021 or possibly even later while
Quentin Tarantino continues to circle
his own eventual r-rated Star Trek
spin-off Noah Hawley will be reportedly
continuing the story that began with JJ
Abrams 2009 outing centered around
captain james t kirk and the crew of the
enterprise NCC 1701 pally who is best
known for the acclaimed TV series Fargo
and legion has been tapped to write
interact a fourth film in the rebooted
Star Trek franchise continuing the
adventures of Kirk Spock who Russ kotti
Sulu and bones on the bottom of the
ocean we've been doing it since last
night
sadly missing from the cast lineup for
the for Star Trek film as Anton Yelchin
who played ships navigator Pavel Chekov
in the first three rebooted Star Trek
films after completing his work on Star
Trek beyond Yelchin was tragically
killed in a 2016 freak accident in his
own driveway at only 27 years old since
beyond was already close to release at
the time of his death Yelchin storyline
didn't lay any groundwork for him to
exit the franchise and the film was
released largely unaltered save for a
card at the end that read simply for
Anton producer JJ Abrams has said that
the role of Chekov will not be recast
for future Star Trek films which means
that if and when Halley's Star Trek
moves into production it will have to
reckon with the absence of a character
who ended the third film with every
intent of returning we appear to be in
the midst of an Eddie Murphy Renaissance
after gradually fading from the
spotlight since its heyday in the 80s
and early 90s
Murphy is suddenly back in a big way
giving a critically acclaimed
performance in 2019 stola meit's is
myname making a triumphant return to
Saturday Night Live as a host lining up
new stand-up comedy specials for Netflix
and announcing sequels to two of his
biggest hits from the 80s coming to
America and February Hills Cop marking
the fourth installment in the Beverly
Hills Cop franchise the newest sequel
will also be a collaboration between
Murphy and Netflix after Paramount
previously pulled the plug on a plan
Beverly Hills Cop for back in 2016
Murphy will be reprise in his role as
Axel Foley the Detroit cop who
repeatedly finds himself travelling to
Beverly Hills to investigate various
crimes
the first Beverly Hills Cop was a smash
success
at the box office in 1984 rising to
become one of the highest-grossing
comedies of all time
although the sequels in 1987 and 1994
brought in diminishing returns there's
no word yet on when Beverly Hills Cop 4
will move into production and Netflix
but considering how fast Murphy star is
once again rising we wouldn't be
surprised if the streaming giant decides
to strike while the iron is hot after
six successful installments in the
found-footage horror franchise
Paranormal Activity is coming back with
a seventh film which will once again
partner Paramount Studios with horror
mega producer Jason Blum although
Paranormal Activity 7 has yet to settle
on a director cast or title the studio
has managed to peg down a release date
March 19 20 21 the studio's also keeping
the story details under wraps but with
six existing films already in the
franchise where you can take some
educated guesses about what a seventh
paranormal activity might look like
after the first film focused on
newlyweds Katie and Mika every
subsequent installment has tied back to
Katie and her family in one way or
another some provide information on
Katie and her sister Kristi's childhood
encounters with a demon while others
detail what happened to Katie following
the events of the first movie however
the Paranormal Activity sequels most
frequently focus on new characters that
happen to encounter Katie and her
demonic companion Toby enabling the
franchise to tell wider and more
intricately entwined stories
[Music]
we expect Paranormal Activity 7 to
continue this trend in some way
introducing a new group of characters
doomed to have their lives ruined by
crossing paths with Katie or her family
keeping with the style of the first six
films we also anticipate the seventh
Paranormal Activity to be presented as
found footage recorded via security
cameras mobile devices and other
household recording equipment nearly a
quarter century after the first scream
slashed its way into theaters a fifth
installment in the deliciously
self-aware horror franchises in the
early stages of development at spyglass
Media Group the original scream released
in 1996 was the brainchild of horror
visionary Wes Craven who passed away in
2015 and Dawson's Creek scribe Kevin
Williamson the screenplay is a near
perfect blend of metahuman and genuine
scares with its cast a horror movie
aficionados frequently contrasting our
characters in a horror movie would act
vs. how they should act there are
certain rules that one must abide by in
order to successfully survive a horror
movie
the film has since spawned three sequels
with the most recent screen for
releasing in 2011 although spyglass
hasn't announced any details about the
fifth screen film other than it's
happening chances seem high that the
cast would include original stars Neve
Campbell Courteney Cox and David
Arquette
who have appeared at all four previous
scream instalments up until now every
screen movie is centered around
Campbell's character Sidney Prescott's
who has the terrible luck of being
repeatedly targeted by a rotating
carousel of killers donning Ghostface
masks well as possible screen 5 could
move away from Sidney and focus on
someone new we'd hoped that Campbell
would be involved in at least some
capacity along with some of the other
familiar faces from the previous screen
movies fans of the gibberish speaking
banana loving henchmen of the despicable
Me movies rejoice a sequel to 2015
spin-off film minions centered on The
Adventures of the tiny terrors is set to
arrive in theaters on July 3rd 2020 this
one will be called minions the rise of
group suggesting that we may be getting
an origin story for the Steve Carell
voiced protagonists of the despicable Me
movies from the perspective of his most
loyal accomplices minions of course
provided audiences with the backstory
for the minions themselves and first
introduced them to GRU as a child so it
would make sense for the sequel to pick
up where that film left off tracing
Bruce
to supervillainy returning for the rise
of Peru is director kyle balda who
previously co-directed both minions and
Despicable Me 3
however Pierre Coe fan who co-directed
every previous Despicable Me film on top
of voicing all the minions will be
stepping away from the co directorial
chair for rise of GRU and will be
replaced by Brad Abelson never fear
though coffin will still be providing
the distinctive voices for the film's
beloved yellow characters
Steve Carell will also likely be
returning giving the GRU centric title
but less clear is whether Sandra Bullock
and Jon Hamm will be repricing their
villainous roles from minions we hope so
even if they're not the main focus it
would be fun to check in with the
Overkill's and see what dastardly things
they're up to check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]